SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
WE HAVE --
TO ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA --
BUT THEY REQUIRE A QUORUM TO
PROCEED SERVE AS THE SECRETARY
TO TAKE THE ROLE.
LASER HERE GLAZER HERE CHANGE
HERE CHIANG HERE ARCHULETA YOUR
FRIDGE LETTER HERE DOT.
DODD HERE GALGIANI [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
LEYVA.
OVER HERE PAN THEIR HAND HERE
WILL PRESENT OFFERS.
ALL RIGHT SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM --
THE FIRST ITEM OF BUSINESS
MEMBERS IS THE ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
COPY ANY QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSSIONS ON THE RULES.
THIS ANY QUESTIONS NOW SENATOR
HELL WILL ANSWER THEM.
IS.
IS THERE A MOTION TO ADOPT THE
RULES MOVE BY SENATOR PAN TO
ADOPT THE RULES SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL GLAZER.
YES LASER HIGH CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
NOT AYE GALGIANI.
HILL -- HILL
AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
AND I WILL.
LOOK AT ALL [inaudible]
WITHOUT.
THE NUMBER THERE SO. EIGHT ZERO
THE OF THE RULES ARE ADOPTED FOR
THE YEAR.
OUR SECOND ITEM OF BUSINESS IS A
LEGISLATION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER WHO IS NOT HERE AT THE
MOMENT BUT WILL GIVE THEM A
COUPLE MINUTES.
I I DON'T BELIEVE THE PREVIOUS
YEAR HAD A PROBLEM ESTABLISH IN
A HEARING AND KEEPING THINGS
MOVING.
JUST A POINT OF RIGHT.
BIG SHOES TO FILL AS ALL I'LL
SAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER WELCOME.
TO THE COMMITTEE YOUR BILL IS --
READY TO BE HEARD AB ONE FORTY
NINE FLOORS YOURS THAT FUTURE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL ACTUALLY
WITH MY GLASSES ON LIKE A
THROUGH A READING.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY NINE
WELL PATIENTS TO RESUME. THREE
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR QUICKLY NEEDED
MEDICATION BY DELAYING THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF NEW REQUIREMENTS ON SECURITY
PRESCRIPTION FORMS.
THIS DELAY IMPLEMENTATION WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MEMBERS OF THE KERRY
PRESCRIPTION FORMS.
ARE VALID WILL ALSO A
PRESCRIBERS TEND TO COMPLY WITH
THE REQUIREMENT TO UTILIZE THESE
NEW SECURITY PRESCRIPTION FORMS
WOULD WRITE PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
MEMBERS KELLY BEAM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
AB ONE FOUR NINE WILL ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIATE NEED FOR PATIENTS
TO ACCESS THEIR MEDICATIONS
WHILE ALLOWING ADEQUATE TIME FOR
PRESCRIBERS PHARMACISTS AND
PRINTERS TO PHASE IN THE UPDATED
PRESCRIPTION PAD.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES --
STOPS WORK ON THE BILL AND FOR
MOVING IT SO QUICKLY THROUGH THE
PROCESS THINKING.
JENNIFER SIGN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES.
YOU CAN IMAGINE LATE DECEMBER
LAST YEAR PHARMACIES REALIZING
THAT THEY NEEDED TO USE NEW
PRESCRIPTION FORMS THAT WERE NOT
IN THEIR HANDS --
AND THEY HAD --
PATIENTS COMING TO THEIR
PHARMACIES ASKING --
FOR PRESCRIPTIONS TO BE FILLED
AND THEY HAD PRESCRIPTION FORMS
THAT WERE VALID SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND MANY OF US GOT --
THOUSANDS OF PHONE CALLS HAVE
NOT ON BOTH THE MEDICAL BOARD IN
THE PHARMACY BOARD WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER IS
WILLING TO CARRY THIS BILL
EMPLOYMENT THIS --
AND IT OF LOGICAL PERIOD OF TIME
THAT ALLOWS THE PRESCRIPTION
FORMS TO BE PRINTED ALLOWS FOR
PRESCRIBERS TO USE THEM AND THEN
GIVES TIME FOR PHARMACIES TO
HAVE THEM IN THEIR HANDS THOSE
VALID PRESCRIPTION FORM SO THEY%
CAN USE THEM IN A VALID WAY WITH --
WITH THEIR PATIENTS --
AND IN ADDITION THE SLOUGHS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO ALSO
REVISED THEIR FORMS TO MAKE SURE
THE STERILIZE NUMBER ISN'T IN
COMPLIANCE WITH.
PHARMACY TRANSACTION STANDARDS
AND WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE DOJ ORIGINALLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAT HAPPENED SO NOW THE
FORMS WILL HAVE THE RIGHT SEIAL
NUMBER INCLUDED AS WELL SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER.
GREAT THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT PLEASE COME ON UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND IDENTIFY
YOURSELF MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ENTRY ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY.
SUPPORT THANK YOU CONNIE DELGADO
FOR THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN SINCE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR CHAU REVERSE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
RENTAL HAGER WITH A CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
MATT ROBERTS IN KAISER
PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANSWER GRAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY IN
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SOMOS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MATT BACK WITH THE OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ZACHARY CORBEAU CALIFORNIA DOWN
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
COOPER REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ORAL MAXILLOFACIAL
SURGEONS IN STRONG SUPPORT A
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER UP ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEN ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RISING ON WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
SELLING AND COOPER RIGHT THERE
IS A AN ISSUE RAISED IN THE
STAFF REPORT.
ON A TYPE OF CAN YOU TELL US HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THAT.
REALLY TAKE IT ERA IT ACTUALLY
AND WE SUBMITTED IT WILL TAKE
APPROPRIATIONS SO AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'LL TAKE AN
APPROPRIATION YES VERY GOOD.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL.
I'D LIKE TO DO I THINK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER FOR
SAVING THE DAY YOU'RE AND GRAY
PUBLIC POLICY AND MOVED THE
MOVIE TIONS.
COLLEAGUES ARE RIGHT SING ON
SENATOR DOT IS MADE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD --
TO PRESS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
WISHES TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING I'D PREFER LETTER.
ARCHULETA I'D DOT DOT AYE
GALGIANI.
HILL.
AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE PAN RIGHT
HAND I'VE WILK [inaudible]
WILL GUIDE.
SO WE HAVE --
PLENTY VOTES TO MOVE THE BILL
OUT BUT WE HAVE TO ADD A MEMBER
ABSENT WILL LEAVE THE ITEM ON
CALL.
THANK YOU SO IN THE COOPER AND
YOUR SUPPORTERS.
ARE LET ME MENTION TO THE BY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL THAT WE
DID HAVE A ANOTHER MEETING
SCHEDULED FOR FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTH.
I KNOW PROFESSIONAL HEARING ON
SURGICAL CENTERS.
UNFORTUNATELY I HAD AT DEATH AND
AND MY FAMILY AND SO.
DO THAT AND WITH YOUR COURTESY
AT WE'RE GONNA MOVE THAT HEARING
SENATE EDUCATION IS READY TO GO
SO.
VERY GOOD SO WHAT.
ALL OF ME CRATE AND IN FACT YET
AT SEA SO WHO WHO REMAINS HE'S
NOT ON IT [inaudible]
I'M NOT.
MY WAITING FOR SENATOR GALGIANI.
OKAY SO I'M GONNA PASS THE GAVEL
TO SENATOR DIED YOU CAN KEEP THE
MATTER ON CALL.
UNTIL A CENTER GALGIANI RIGHTS
OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
.
AB ONE FORTY NINE MISSION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT BOATS EIGHT
ZERO GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE [inaudible]
THE BILL. NINE OH AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE IN THIS MEETING IS NOW.
ADJOURNED